صغيره متروكه لا تلقى من يمسكها فالخوف من
الحرب دفعهم للهروب ليستيقظوا في امان
الوحده ببلد اخر منظمه يونيسف دقت ناقوس
الخطر مع تاكيدها عبور مئات الاطفال غير
المصحوبين بذويهم الحدود التشاديه للفرار
من القتال في السودان حيث ادى القتال الى
فصل العائلات اجبار القاصرين على القيام
بالرحله الشاقه عبور حدود تمتد على طول
الف كيلو متر دون والديهم اضافه ان المزيد
والمزيد للاطفال يصلون بمفردهم الى البلد
المجاور الذي فر اليه اكثر من 100 الف
لاجئ ستونا في المئه منهم دون سن 18 عاما
المدير القطري لمنظمه يونيسف في تشاد جاك
بويل اكد تحديدا 267 طفلا غير مصحوبين
بدويهم حتى اللحظه مرجحا ان يكون رقم
الحقيقي اكثر بكثير لفتى الى صعوبه هذه
الصعوبه وصعوبه مهمه لم الشمل او تحديد
مكان الوالدين بسبب طول الحدود بين
البلدين كما ذكرنا وضعف شبكه الاتصالات
وعدم تسجيل العائلات وحتى الاطفال بشكل
صحيح في المخيمات الرسميه هذا وحضرت
وكالات الاغاثه من ان القصر غير المصحوبين
بدويهم هم الاكثر ضعفا نظرا الى النعماله
الاطفال او الاستغلال الجنسي تشكلان خطرا
حقيقيا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات